president biden praised the agreement in
his most extensive remarks about the
conflict since it began
i believe the palestinians and israelis
equally deserve to live safely and
securely
and to enjoy equal measures of freedom
prosperity and democracy
my administration will continue our
quiet and relentless diplomacy toward
that
end wija zhang joins us now from the
white house wiesha how did the president
handle
his first foreign policy crisis good
morning anthony
president biden said very little in
public as the conflict
was unfolding focusing instead on what
the white house called
quiet relentless diplomacy in private
many democrats were calling on the
president to publicly support a
ceasefire even
earlier than he did but a senior
administration official told cbs news
that mr biden's experience during
previous conflicts in the middle east
led him to
deliberately take this behind the scenes
approach
and that he believes it's more effective
to work that way instead of getting
drawn into public political arguments
the formal statement from israeli prime
minister benjamin netanyahu's office
called the ceasefire an egyptian
initiative with no credit to the united
states still
the administration had more than 80
talks with officials in the region
including six conversations
between mr biden and netanyahu the
president said he sees a genuine
opportunity to make progress toward
peace in the middle east
and said he would work with israel and
the palestinian authority though not
hamas which the u.s
considers a terrorist organization he
also said he would help
israel replenish supplies for its iron
dome
despite opposition from some democrats
over selling weapons
to israel in fact just yesterday senator
bernie sanders offered
a new resolution to block the
administration's planned
735 million dollar arms deal
to israel he says that that could offer
even
more conflict but the president has made
clear that strengthening relationships
with allies like
israel is a cornerstone of his foreign
policy strategy
and in the next few days his secretary
of state will visit
the middle east gail thank you very much